est ce que vous pensez de du mouvement
actuel qui est encore de mettre en avant
des femmes avec des mensurations de rêve
même si là aussi ça change un petit peu
quand même
well as des anorexiques quand même enfin
c'est des femmes avec des mensurations
qui sont pas à la portée de tout le
monde court de miss france ouais en ce
moment c'est sûr que pour l'instant
c'est pas les femmes rondes qui est
amusant
déjà je pense qu'il faudrait arrêter de
faire des concours comme ça nos pensées
merci très sale où l'agriculture ça va
quoi j'étais la dernière à la plus belle
vache ou la barre d'ombessa enfin j'ai
une amie j'ai un ami qui l'a fait il ya
un an deux ans je sais plus elle m'a
expliqué un petit peu tous les coulisses
où cédric là enfin je suis mes gars
contre ce à quoi parce que c'est
vraiment on est dans la sexualisation
qu'on le veuille ou non est grand disent
que c'est pas le cas c'est complètement
le cas elle son soutif culotte et c'est
très bien je pose à poil donc j'ai pas
de problème avec la nudité mais on est
dans un truc de 2,2 à shine même pas les
mots tellement jeu a été valorisé juste
partons par ton corps mais oui ça va
tuer jugé plus ou moins bien que ta
copine c'est comme les vaches sans
vraiment ces voix-là 6-3 times et non
mais pardon les pauvres elle se rend
même pas compte c'est vraiment c'est
celle qui a la plus belle robe la plus
belle couleur la plus belle crinière
comme un poney ci ont préféré celle où
chaque mois mais en tout cas voilà c'est
la plus belle jument le trois mois ça me
fait vos meilleurs rôles à l'avenir
france qui a gagné
moi j'ai pas la télé donc je suis très
long tout ça mais la miss france qui a
gagné l'année dernière elle a été
traitée de grosse mais regardons sont
coordonnés correctement fin et si l on
la traite de grosse excusez moi mais
celles qui font 1,42 elles vont être
remplies de complexe donc finalement je
sais pas qui c'était peut-être vous
qu'ils disaient qu'on se remet un peu
d'aidé
des choses qu'on nous a dit étant enfant
malheureusement pas toujours il ya des
jours serment bien certainement certains
voudraient je suis très impatient de
connaître l'avis de vincent avec passion
que ça peut être un bon moment m'a
changé comment vis tu te fais plaisir ça
te fait plaisir je veux dire t'as pas de
complexe trouve ça tu crois que c'est à
des complexes je sais pas moi je sais
pas j'ai pas un psychologue non plus
après et n'a pu me disent ça tu peux pas
le voir
peut-être y en a d'autres qui peuvent
pas pouvoir connaître
est-ce que ça part d'une démarche de
vouloir être nue à la base aussi
davodeau de vouloir être j appelle
jeunes qui font des photos de nu et qui
aiment simple est-ce que sa part de ça
aussi
voilà parce que c'est ça quand même
après que tu te serves de ton corps soit
maigre grosse machine après si tout le
monde s'en fout tu vois moi j'ai pas la
tête de brad pitt non plus tu vois que
tout le monde merci c'est gentil je veux
dire c'est que voilà c'est pas pour moi
c'est pas c'est pas un énorme débat ce
que tu fais ça te plaît mais c'est très
bien qu'on ne jugez pas les nanas qu'il
faut ça me fera plaisir aux filles ça
n'en fait plus est-ce que je te jure
tout le monde
elie semoun en face à la convention ont
procédé qui devrait plus exister tout ça
donc on va pérenniser les réseaux
sociaux ce quelque chose de très récents
et la volonté de s'exhiber sur la
censure pendant six ans peu comme un
monde à comment ça si c'est vrai j'aime
faire acteur je suis peut-être
narcissique j'ai peut-être de l'ego mais
je vais pas me montrer les roues a l'air
sûr sur les réseaux sociaux
tout continue on n'est pas dans la
grossophobie ou d'un on est avant tout
dans la vie de faire de l'artiste de
poser du l'intéressé à droite personne
dans ce débat c'est que pour qu'on soit
comédiens pour soi chanteur c'est du
narcissisme ans et de l'ego qui société
chanteuse je suis comédienne je sais
bien que c'est d'abord légaux qui est là
parce qu'on a envie de remplir notre ego
et de machins et de nourrir des choses
ok une fois que ces acquis et que et
qu'on ne se demande pas là dessus
déjà c'est bien de le savoir au-delà de
ça en fait il ya une différence entre
les pertes ces filles qui participent à
ce concours et la création de ce
concours qui soit pour moi deux choses
mais alors totalement différente on va
pas rentrer dans ce sujet parce que ça
va être très très long au delà de sa
fabrique ont vu juste quand tu viens
vous disiez que tu allais que ce que je
fais est sympa et deux ans de plus
non mais que quand tu dis que ce que je
fais sympa et ça peut me faire plaisir
tu veux que je te dise ça va le message
des grosses c'est d'abord d'où toi tu te
fais plaisir à l'abri des bombes comme
un peu forte mais je sais pas pourquoi
elle est passée par le nu pour justement
se faire un électrochoc accepter son
blog le ballon justement ce message à
des gamines en disant voilà tu te
considères comme forte et bars regardes
tu peux mettre à poil comment être qui
fait un peu c'est juste ça parce que
nous sommes en amont et biberonné mais
vraiment pas je m'en fous j'en porte un
peu partout je redescend très bien c'est
vrai vous ne plus réclamer son gain de
2,2 de commandant de corps auquel on
doit sembler moi j'ai pas envie de
ressembler à 1,30 cache pas que je
trouve très bien je suis moi je sais que
faire contre ça on est pas me poser la
question de savoir si à un moment le
concours des miss france avait pas à
contribuer à ouvrir les gens dans les
années 60 je pars en quelle année ça a
démarré mais en tout cas est-ce que ça
n'ait pas été savait pas fait basculer
vers vers l'émancipation de la femme
quelque chose comme ça il n'y a pas eu
ce à un moment je pose je peux juste la
question est est-ce que cela freman en
c1
non mais c'est un peu plus haut mais en
même temps c'est un concours de beauté
alors à ce moment-là si les gens veulent
regarder ça et s'acheva moi je suis pas
ni pour ni contre je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas où je mets d'où la beauté c'est
que du trot mais alors je suis d'accord
allez dire mais mais mais je suis pas
d'accord avec ça évidemment parce que
effectivement tes photos sont
magnifiques enfin régulière en plus à
une gueule d'ange
donc je veux dire mais c'est à chacun de
se positionner par rapport à suri est ce
qu'elle est c'est l'éducation aussi par
rapport aux autres effectivement en
disant bas excusez moi mais non mais je
fais ce que je fais ce que je veux et je
suis vous êtes belle quoi enfin bon et
après ses dépositions chacun mais j'ai
pas s'il faut arrêter continuer chacun a
son truc ce faisant parce qu'il ya
peut-être des nanas qui ont 20 ans qui
sont rondes et qui ont envie de faire
mais c'est long elle ne le savait qu'en
france il ya des souffrances blondasse
vrai concours sont situés à anvers
louvain c'est simple c'est à dire que
chacun fait bien son nom elle veut de
son corps et de tout ça